one of the things that i
i found interesting um is that you often
say that happiness is a choice totally a
choice and you also often say that
saying that is very controversial and it
loses you or whatever percentage of
podcast listeners who don't want to
believe that happiness is a choice it
loses me exactly eight percent if my
statistics are correct eight yeah
i'll tell you why when i wrote when i
wrote solve for happy the first time
i uh i basically wrote it like we write
software i created a beta version put it
online
invited people to come and read it
literally on google docs i would invite
them to walk in and edit
my words which was an amazing experience
270 people to be exact and you know i
asked them to do a little survey to tell
me a little bit about themselves before
that and because it's on docs you can
actually follow how the readers are
progressing and i lost eight percent of
my readers on page 11
okay and page 11 was the page where i
said happiness is a choice
and and it's obvious because for so many
people
being the victim
is a very interesting place to be
interesting yeah it's because of course
there is
value to being the victim
okay so remember a lot of what we are as
humans comes from when you were younger
so as a two-year-old you you know how
you sometimes i know you did sometimes
you would go like mommy
and you pretend to cry oh yeah right why
would you pretend to cry because crying
allowed your mom to go like okay baby
something's wrong either you know tap
you on the back or remove whatever was
annoying you or whatever just give you
attention
so there is a utility to that and for
some reason
as i i always say most of our problems
with happiness are because some of us
decided not to grow beyond sex
oh okay okay yeah so so you know after a
while you start to tell yourself there's
no utility to that there isn't you know
i i can actually get up myself and get
the nutella jar that i wanted i don't
have to wait for mommy anymore why am i
crying yeah right or i can actually take
charge of my life
you know if life is a little challenging
i can cry for mommy but mommy's not
going to show up if my boss is annoying
and and when you're stuck in that space
for some of us there is a utility of i'm
the victim which means i have no
responsibility for my unhappiness okay
it's life life is treating me bad no
life is treating everyone bad
occasionally right or you know
i don't have to really go out of my way
to do my homework to be happy or to do
my homework to be fit or to do my
homework to you know to make my
relationship work well and there is an
interesting comfort in that
it's like i'm i'm
you know i don't need to do anything
about it because there is nothing to be
done about it it's the responsibility of
life and not me
but that's not true
happiness is a choice and it's you know
i always tell people the simplest way to
understand that is you can obsess about
the comment your partner told you
all through your commute to work
okay and the minute you get to work your
boss says
you know where is the report we asked
for or you have to be in a meeting and
what do you do you tell your brain okay
brain that's it we can't think about
this for now focus on the meeting and
throughout the meeting you're okay
throughout the meeting you're sitting
there you're listening at them
attentively and you're not thinking
about this issue you're probably
thinking about how boring the meeting is
yeah but you're not unhappy about that
issue at all the minute you walk out of
the meeting you're go you go like okay
but my partner said this on friday let's
play it again it's a choice yeah
and i i i hosted on slo-mo on on my
podcast i hosted uh dr jill balti taylor
which is definitely one of my favorite
humans on the planet so jill is a
neuroscientist
and
she
analyzes the brain's relationship with
unhappiness i refer to her a lot in in
my book
and
she her studies will show you that
from the time take any negative emotion
take anger for example from the time an
event triggers you
to the time you're flooded with stress
hormones to the time you take a reaction
or you don't to the time the hormones
are flooded out of your body is 90
seconds
that's it you can't hold your anger that
that over
physiological response is 90 seconds so
i asked her and i said so jill what does
that mean why do people stay angry for
years and she said they regenerate it
every 90 seconds
so so every 90 seconds you're you have
the ability to say your your body is
saying okay here is a buffer
do you need me to be is there still a
threat should i still be stressed okay
and you go like yeah but my partner said
this and you get angry again and again
and again for 90 seconds and for most of
us we're so creative so you know your
partner says something hurtful on a
friday on saturday you say he must be
cheating on me on sunday you say all the
things i do for them but you know they
do they don't do for me you and and you
can make it much worse we're very very
creative every 90 seconds and that's why
we stay unhappy that's why we stay angry
yeah
that's that's really interesting i i not
come across a 90 second thing before but
i think that's like this this idea that
you know in between stimulus and
response exactly there is a gap
absolutely and that's a gap that we in
which we can choose a response
absolutely it's an idea like for example
the stoics i've been talking about for
ages as well and it's it's cool how
modern science is now showing this to be
true okay a few a few questions on this
point the the first one is
so obviously i'm also on board with this
idea that happiness is a choice but
anytime i say that i feel a niggling
part of myself because i know that some
people will be thinking
what about
child abuse what about depression what
about clinical anxiety what about
post-traumatic stress disorder what
about all of these other extreme things
is it really fair to say happiness is a
choice
is that like just telling a depressed
person to cheer up um and i've never
quite been able to answer that sorry
that's a great question by the way so
absolute happiness is not a choice
nobody's ever always happy okay i had
the joy of spending an hour and a half
with his holiness the dalai lama i i
know most of the top monks in the world
who have practiced for 40 50 60 years i
mean someone like matthew rickard which
again is a very dear friend and i hosted
on slo-mo is a person that is
done 60 000 hours of meditation of
lifetime meditation okay and i asked him
and i said matthew are you always happy
and he said of course not i'm always
pissed off
okay and he and he and he's very open
about it it's like he's the state of the
world if you have compassion
makes you feel a negative emotions
of course if you have chronic pain if
you have been subjected to abuse
if you've lost someone that you love
it is it's not the same uh uh ease of
finding happiness
that then like if you went wanted to buy
a sandwich and your place was closed you
know your favorite or they didn't have
your favorite sandwich some of us feel
unhappy about that and it's absolutely a
choice not to right it's not comparable
to i've been abused
the question is
in relative terms
in relative terms which is which is what
matters losing my child could make me
miserable
nobody would blame me for that
but also in relative terms from that new
low point of my life
so ali ali my son died because of a
medical error you know basically they
made a mistake in a very simple five
mistakes in a very simple surgical
operation
now
i hugged him before he went into the
operating room i promise you the highest
point of my life okay he was handsome he
was tall he was strong he was every
father's dream
and then
four hours later ali is gone
four hours later my new baseline of
happiness in life has gone from here to
here
and you can make a choice to stay here
or you can make a choice to make it
slightly better and slightly better and
slightly better
yeah i may never return back to that
high point i may never return back to a
place of absolute happiness of you know
remembering my son and not missing him
but i have the choice to make that
incremental bit and that incremental bit
is within the hands of every one of us
and that incremental bit interestingly
is the wise choice hey friends thank you
so much for watching if you enjoyed this
clip then click here for the full
unedited episode and if you like that
then do please consider subscribing to
the channel it means a lot thank you so
much and have a great day